les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france 24 una isla de
naturaleza en medio del hormigón o aqua
mater la nueva exposición de sebastiáo
salgado no deja indiferentes a los
trabajadores que a diario visitan el
centro de negocios de la defensa en
parís la muestra del fotógrafo y también
ecologista brasileño intenta
sensibilizar sobre el agua un recurso
amenazado en diferentes sitios del
planeta un reportaje que nos ofrecen
erika olavarría y miriam bengalí
mil metros cuadrados de bambú en medio
de las torres del barrio de negocios de
la defensa en parís sede de las
principales multinacionales francesas el
pabellón inspirado en una maloca una
construcción indígena colombiana expone
en su interior 40 obras del reconocido
fotógrafo franco brasileño sebastiáo
salgado con motivo de una exposición
organizada por la unesco
que
es una exposición que muestra casi todos
los aspectos del agua el agua en
abundancia en los océanos o en los
grandes ríos hasta la escasez de agua
televisión vienés y creo que es muy
importante que la gente venga y vea esta
aridez que levantamos chico esta selva
de cemento se forja de bp y un software
y ya en el centro está esta flor de
bambú que representa la pureza de la
naturaleza
el autor del pabellón es el arquitecto
colombiano simón vélez que busca
devolverle al bambú su justo valor y
persistente es considerado un acero
natural ya la vez una madera renovable
en momentos en que los recursos
naturales son cada vez más escasos esto
va a poder ser una alternativa a dejar
en paz el bosque
para dejarlo en paz porque es un pasto
tu corta es el pasto de tu jardín y
nuestras matando el pastor pasto vuelve
y crece tu cortas un bambú sal y él
vuelve y retoño siempre digo que la
arquitectura tiene que ser más
vegetariana la arquitectura que tenía
que parecer más a la comida tiene que
tener un componente mineral que en este
caso es del concreto del acero el vidrio
el ladrillo y un componente orgánico
como las maderas como el bambú
sensibilizar a la fragilidad del agua
este recurso vital desde un pabellón
vegetal esa es la ambición de la
exposición agua mater instalada hasta
septiembre en la explanada de la defensa
[Música]
en las paredes de san blas parte del
barrio de petare en la capital
venezolana caracas no son las fotos
sobre el agua lo que está expuesto sino
unos 600 retratos en blanco y negro de
los residentes la operación fue
organizada por la fundación inside out
del artista francés j r del que ya
hablamos hace unas semanas en la
relación con su retrato gigante de una
línea en ucrania el objetivo con esta
nueva acción en venezuela es dar una
imagen más positiva al que es
considerado el barrio más marginal de
sudamérica escuchamos a juan calero el
director del proyecto y autor de algunas
de las fotos me parece que dignificar a
las personas en un lugar tan variopinto
y tan multicolor como es san blas es
algo muy bonito para la comunidad toda
la comunidad cada vez que se ven sus
retratos se queda impresionado al
principio cuando le decía esto va a ser
una foto para imprimirla daban como
reacios pero después hacían colas cada
uno para tomarse su foto y querían
participar y fue una avalancha a gente
nos quedamos con el poder de las
imágenes pero que se mueven y que van a
competir en el festival de cannes ya se
conoce la selección oficial de la
edición número 75 del prestigioso
festival francés que se celebrará del 16
al 28 de mayo y de las más de 2.200
películas que se presentaron al comité
de selección al final 18 obras entraron
en la carrera por la palma de oro este
año se espera la presencia en la
alfombra roja de muchas estrellas del
cine y la swinton idrís elba para la
nueva película de george miller el
director de mad max veremos también a
anthony hopkins le ha sido y kristen
stewart para los crímenes del futuro de
david cronenberg y la encargada de
iniciar la velada es una obra francesa 7
como z de niveles de análisis el remake
de una película japonesa de se ubique
por el tráiler promete ser una locura
para mí
pasamos ahora a los estrenos musicales
de artistas que siempre dan en el blanco
la canción aquí se de la talentosa
cantautora belgo congoleña luz endo y
acusa ha anunciado un segundo disco muy
esperado después de gol en el 2020 que
la había llevado a la cima
[Música]
probablemente ya han escuchado estas
notas porque así pues la nueva canción
de heart y style está batiendo récords
en internet y en la radio con una
melodía poderosa y una voz tan delicada
como siempre el cantante inglés y ex
miembro de la boy band one direction
continúa su ascenso
[Música]
y en por última vez button y se une al
rey del reggaeton daddy yankee un título
que resuena atrás del reciente anuncio
de que dejara su carrera musical de
forma permanente
no lo quiero
amor
y para los amantes del arte dramático
nos despedimos con el tráiler del
festival iberoamericano de teatro en
bogotá 30 obras nacionales e
internacionales y 140 de teatro de calle
que pueden ver hasta el domingo 17 de
abril en la capital colombiana gracias
por su confianza y cuídense
[Aplausos]
[Música]